What I wanted to do was take the tropes
of the Slasher movie.
-AHHHH.
and use them for gay celebration.
I am so grateful to be a part of a movie
that has authentic representation.
And I think it'll get people talking.
101 take one.
Common mark A and B.
A and B common mark.
When I was growing up,
I loved Slasher movies.
Good morning,
ladies and gentlemen.
Horror films have a
very complicated relationship
with gender and sexual identity.
I can't make you straight,
but you give us this week.
We might be able to help.
What I wanted to do was
take the tropes of the Slasher movie
and use them for gay celebration.
Boys' cabin over there. Girls'
cabin over there.
I use they/them pronouns.
As in, they can't believe
they're at this fucking camp.
I've started in Slasher films
over a really long time ago.
What's really brilliant about
what John has done with the script is
to take a fairly traditional
camp Slasher movie.
- Who is that?
- And layer on top of that.
- Come in, please.
- Is the horror of a place
that believes that they can
convert people with
pseudo therapy techniques.
It's scary because
"conversion therapy" is abuse,
and it is torture that messes
with your entire being.
Do you think your parents
are disappointed in you?
Sometimes.
So what do you do?
You try to make yourself special.
You become...
They.
I think we're bringing awareness
to what's actually
happening in the world.
- It's time to play.
-To hopefully bring
an end to the
horror that happens
at these camps.
I have zero interest
in not being gay.
There's no judgments
in this room.
-When it came to
casting the seven campers,
it was very important to me
to cast queer actors.
- Sometimes I wish I was invisible.
- Because, we have
been so underrepresented
in terms of playing ourselves.
- John said, I would like to have
young people who identify
with any one of these campers
and root for someone
that they see in themselves.
I am a gay
Korean-American woman.
I am so grateful and honored
to be a part of a movie
that has authentic representation
told by authentic storytellers.
The best way that we can assure
we are making the best art
is to include as many and as diverse
a population of people possible.
Every single character represents
a different section
of the queer experience.
- I know what I am?
What are you?
It's just a different environment.
I haven't seen before.
Finding my own truth
and celebrating my uniqueness.
The most important
thing to remember is
it's an entertaining movie.
I didn't set out to write a lecture.
If you love Horror movies,
if you love human
drama and thrillers,
this is the movie for you.
- This should be cozy.
To even see this
concept manifest on screen
I think that John is a genius.
- Today, we're going to be exploring
traditional gender roles.
We are creating something
completely new here,
and I don't have
a comparison in my head.
We subvert a lot
of Slasher tropes.
-AHHH!
So I'm like, What's going to happen?
Taste?
We need to get out of here.
What are we supposed to do?
We're trapped.
There's going to
be a lot of surprises.
- And I think it'll
get people talking.
Shhh.
AHHHH!
You trust me, don't you?